and i don't know about you but when i
was on my easter break it finally felt
like life was back to normal properly
back to normal
is the kovid pandemic finally over do
you think
yes in this country
the cove it's obviously endemic
meaning that it's everywhere and
lots of people catch it
but you know every week they publish
this
statistics of how many people have got
antibodies to protect you from covert
and it's now over 99
and
that's that's great and it means that we
can have what is essentially a free
existence here
is but it's not over everywhere around
the world in fact i think you know one
of the really shocking things
as is watching how some of the countries
that went for a zero covered strategy at
the start
are now in real trouble
negotiating their way to being you know
part of the international community
again the reason i'm asking you is
because for the
nhs the sort of fallout as you were
saying is still quite extreme
for the nhs i had a look at the stats
before
we sat down on april the 11th there were
301 deaths and 40 000
cases
people on waiting lists for treatment
record levels of 6.2 million a e waiting
times worse since recalls began trolley
weights at record levels i mean i bet
you're glad that this isn't your job to
fix this anymore huh um
and crucially the number of vacant
hospital
uh beds in england's lower than at any
time since the start of the crisis and
you know that's a
key measure of resilience yeah i mean if
you had a close family member that
needed nhs treatment against that
backdrop would you be would you be
worried about that
well
i think
that
fixing this is clearly critical
and there's a plan in place the
government put a plan in place um
to tackle this backlog
but you know
a year ago thinking about how to tackle
the backlog post the
uh the the pandemic was a priority and
then we had omicron over last christmas
and so it's obviously really serious and
it will take time to get through that
backlog
of you know things that were postponed
so you know that's why i said the
pandemic's over but we're still with the
hangover and the impact on the nhs and
remember the people who work in the nhs
are tired as well they must be so tired
um so so there's a big you know that's a
it's a big challenge they're probably so
tired that when you say as a former
health sector it's over they might even
feel a bit irritated by that because
they might be thinking it's really not
over for us we're dealing with this
still day in day out well the
consequences are still there absolutely
but the that's the difference between a
disease being you know pandemic
affecting everybody in our normal lives
and just and endemic as a bad disease
you know another flu let's look back
briefly on the plan you've talked about
this loads as an inquiry you've given
evidence to celebrances i don't want to
go on and on about it but you are here
yeah and you did live through it and you
did do a lot of decision-making around
it yeah um on the positive uh the
vaccine task force has been widely
praised led by kate bingham you actually
by the select committee were praised for
personally taking charge of the testing
system although they were critical of
test and trace
um
there's some of the couple of successes
what do you think were the biggest
mistakes when you reflect back on it
what do you think i wish i had done that
differently
well i think there's quite a lot of
things that we need to learn from
both from the good and the bad so it's
really important to learn from the
things that went well as well uh it's a
bit like um after a football match you
know the team that wins uh you win 2-1
and everyone says wow that was an
amazing performance everything went
right well yeah except that you're
letting you let a goal in so let's learn
from the successes as well we can learn
from the vaccination program uh getting
external expertise in yeah from
including from business from
academia and and clinicians that team
absolutely brilliant also completely
giving them their head and saying
we want you to buy from around the world
we want you to and basically you know
the price is less important because the
saving to the economy of getting this
right is so big so there were a couple
of big learning points uh from the
successes
um and then but there were areas that
were uh that were problematic what what
what's your biggest regret well
one of the things i point to is some of
the some of the rules that were put in
place the way that they were interpreted
on the ground
um and that the restrictions you mean
yeah so for instance do you remember
early in
2020 during the first lockdown
um
there were funerals that took place
without their loved ones yes you know
you regret that i i do because it and so
that was incredibly upsetting
um
and that was because
of
it it wasn't the intention but it was
the consequence of the rules and we then
we saw that happen and we changed it but
nevertheless you've you know you've got
to be
your biggest personal regret well that
was that was one of them
um but you know the thing is in it
managing something
as big as a pandemic you know
you're never going to get every decision
right your aim is to get most decisions
right and especially when something is
genuinely unprecedented and
one thing i did want to ask you
specifically on was was the issue of
care homes i know you've been asked a
lot about it but was that is that
something now in retrospect
you wish you had done differently well
discharging people
into care homes without being tested no
i'm going to give you a different
explanation of what happened and i've
thought obviously thought about this a
lot well you've been asked to i mean and
it will be a big focus of the inquiry it
will
and so what the inquiry what the um
evidence shows
is that the number of infections that
got into care homes from people being
discharged from hospital was very very
low
so there's been a i've got here an
estimated 25 000 people were discharged
from hospitals into care homes without
getting a test well that's when the
height of the epidemic in the spring
2020 yeah so that's that's when there
weren't tests widely available before
we'd managed to scale up the testing
yeah um
the
that must be a regret though muscle nerd
isn't it well if you let me explain what
actually happened rather than what is
the narrative around this because this
is somewhere where the narrative is
wrong and it's really important we
correct it and learn the right lessons
not the wrong ones so around two percent
of infections got into care homes
through that discharge process part of
the reason is that because there wasn't
a test everyone was put into isolation
so i can't
you know if you can come up with a
better option of what to do with people
who need to leave hospital and go back
to their care home you know um putting
everyone in isolation that was the
policy now the level of isolation will
have been different in different care
homes um
the challenge in terms of where the
infection came from
is that everybody in the community lots
of people were catching covered and
inevitably working in people worked in
care homes but i didn't want to go and
stand on that podium and effectively um
say that i'm terribly sorry this came
from the staff who live in the community
going no it came from a mix didn't it
well so they've they've done the
analysis and found actually the big
change that we made that really affected
this
and meant that the the likelihood of
catching covert in the cairn was so much
lower in the second wave was that we
stopped people moving staff moving
between between him and that actually
was a much much bigger impact so this
comes back to the lessons piece yes of
course one of the lessons is you know
don't just charge people who haven't
been tested you know what i'm going to
answer the question and then you can ask
your next one rather than you aren't
finishing myself i thought we're having
a conversation but okay i'd love to have
a conversation but the conversation
involves listening to the answer my
question right your question right so
okay so the the point is this right
that the
um the the
policy of discharge involved the pro
everybody going into isolation because
we didn't know whether they had covered
um
the big impact
that really protected uh care homes was
when we said you can't work in more than
one care home yeah so for the one of the
lessons we need to learn is you put that
policy in place right yeah and then the
other
in terms of discharges is you must have
a testing system ready to go because we
had to build that from scratch so those
are the two lessons so you
that's fine so you do agree that that
was a mistake to allow people to be
discharged from hospital without being
tested no because you're saying it's
both things no i'm saying it's that we
didn't have the tests in place
so the lesson on that front is have the
tests be ready with the testing system
ready to go because and the reason i'm
i'm sort of um really clear on this
point and may you know emphatic about it
is that um
leaving people in hospital longer than
they
need to be in hospital is also bad for
them
and bad for the people who otherwise
need to be in hospital
so the discharge policy had a had an
important merit behind it yeah
so so what so what i really think on
care homes and what i hope is coming
over is that is that there is a
narrative about what went wrong in care
homes um fundamentally the narrative is
wrong
and part of the job of the inquiry and
part of the lessons learned learning
exercise yes is to learn the right
lessons including from things that
didn't go as well as they could have
done yeah but that was the narrative we
heard from a lot of care home bosses
wasn't it that people were being
discharged and bringing this is the
point this is why we're having the
discussion because um
because it's actually important to
listen to the science and look at the
evidence and learn the lessons from the
science and the evidence
not say well because that was on the
front page of the newspapers at the time
it must have been true because that
isn't actually what happened the main
thing that happened is that i was the
infection
we could spend a long a lot of time
talking about this because dominic
cummings said that you told the pm
anyone going into a care home would be
tested
uh even if you disputed that you did
tell the public there was a protective
ring and then people found that people
were going that hadn't been tested i
take your will without staff okay we can
go through i'm just saying is it
you seem to be saying that i'm i'm
saying that he thinks it's not well no
i'm not i'm saying no so the point about
dom cummings is you know you're wrong um
so that's not important um the point
what is important is that we know as a
society
next time there's a pandemic because
there will be one we know how best to
protect people in care homes and if we
learn the wrong lessons
then we will not do it next time as well
as possible and the thing i really care
about
is that the person in my shoes next time
has like a manual on the on the you know
has a testing regime yeah but also more
broadly than that has a manual on the
shelf yeah says you know this is how you
do it because we didn't have that at all
yeah um except in some specific areas
all of which will come out in the
inquiry which i think will be useful for
everyone to get get the facts out there
yeah um let's move on though because i
would like to talk to you more about
that but i'm going to run out of time
okay so
i want to talk to you about cover
casting a long shadow in other ways yeah
and and specifically at the moment on
the career of a prime minister who's now
being fined by the police for attending
a cavid event he could an event that was
deemed as breaching uh the rules
and he could receive more penalties as
you know he's under investigation for
other events and there's been a number
of fines for people within downing
street and government
but you don't believe the pm should
resign
over this why not
because i think that when you're looking
at
who should be the prime minister you've
got to look in the round you've got to
look at the big picture
on covid i think that we got the big
calls right
um and there's a war
and the prime minister is leading the
international response to vladimir putin
and so you've got to look forward and
you've got to take everything into
account
does that does your
decision stay the same however many
finds he gets or however
much the public and the polling uh
reflects an anger in amongst the public
does this
of course i understand that anger and
the prime minister's apologized
and you've got to look at where we are
now and what's happening now in the
world and you know we're in this phase
of history where you know big things
keep coming along you know no longer no
we just sorted brexit when the pandemic
hit and then you're the pat we were just
coming out of the pandemic when the war
started and
we've got to make sure i was like what
is in the national interest you're that
is what matters
and you are speaking as a politician and
a loyal lieutenant to the the prime
minister
but it must resonate with you
on a personal level too because
you did resign you
yeah had a relationship with someone it
became
public in a way that was obviously
difficult for you and your families
um
you were found to have broken guidelines
you resigned
do you feel bitter looking back about
being exposed in that way and forced to
resign and you don't
feel that there's a contradiction in the
prime minister's behaviour how do you
feel about it on a personal level now no
i i wasn't uh forced by anybody to
resign i chose to resign and the
you know in a way it makes
makes the point more powerfully
that you in the prime minister you have
to look at who is
best placed right now to be leading this
country with the challenges that we face
and especially you know
the response to
vladimir putin
is the single most important
international thing going on right now
and responding to the costs of the
million crisis domestically
i mean people would also say that
prime ministers have been changed at
times during war we aren't actually
directly at war in the uk but the
problem is much rolled out it's
bigger than that but some of your
colleagues would disagree with that well
people disagree in politics that's the
nature of this thing
in fact i'd argue that in the democracy
uh the disagreement is the point uh and
some of our um opponents strategically
who think that you should have an
autocracy and not have disagreement
don't get the point that this cacophony
of debate isn't a weakness it's a
strength it's the point of politics so
of course people disagree with me but
that but that's how you feel but that
how i feel about it is you've got to
look what is in the national interest is
you know essentially vladimir zolensky's
closest international ally the guy who
has played an absolutely leading role in
ensuring the strategic response to putin
is not to split the west which is what
putin wanted and i think expected but to
unite the uh the west um and
you know most of the rest of the world
can i come back to your to your
situation because you
you had these photos leaked of you and
and gina who you're now in in a
relationship with
and the information commission's office
has said there's not enough evidence to
prosecute the people suspected of
leaking that footage
i mean it was in your private office i
mean this was security how do you feel
about that do you just want it is it
just done now yeah i've said everything
i'm ever going to say on that subject so
do you want them to be prosecuted you
just i'm just i'm just yeah
i'm just absolutely not going there
you're not gonna go there okay
i'm matt hancock to finish off um
you came into parliament in 2010 you
became a minister i remember in 2012.
you were in the cabinet by 28
and then you had
this massive bump in the road for your
career that wasn't just political but
also personal
did you sort of think about just packing
it in and
and doing something else and beginning a
new life in a different career rather
like your mentor
george osborne did after 2015. did you
give that some thought well obviously
when something huge happens like that
you think about
you know you think about everything
across the board
um
but
the other thing is you know i've got a
job to do representing my
constituents you know and i love doing
that and i've been able to spend far
more time on it in the last year than i
did
i did before and also
being in parliament is a real privilege
um
you have a platform
to
talk about and make changes on areas you
really care about so take the campaign
that i'm running on dyslexia you know
i'm dyslexic
and didn't find out until you're at
university exactly i don't know how you
might you got to oxford based on maths
basically you basically got to oxford
university not knowing that you were
dyslexic yeah but uh thankfully i'm very
good at math so i appreciate how i'm one
of the lucky ones who got through
but still one in five dyslexic kids only
one in five get identified at school and
we've got to change that and the the
department have now uh made some changes
and put out a green paper about this and
so you know that is you know
making change from the back benches on
the subject i really care about
personally affects me and
i i wasn't able to do because i was in
different ministerial roles in
government and so you know that
you know i i love doing that
other former cabinet ministers said to
me after i resigned they said you know
the problem is going to be you know
you've gone from your time being
programmed out to every five minutes you
know sometimes my lube breaks were
programmed into the diary were you all
like breaks are actually written in no
really i wanted to know this not every
day but on business literally written
busy days yeah
the secretary of state can go for a
comfort break yeah and five minutes and
then and then you know back at your desk
and then um
and then going to having you know a lot
more um freedom in how you use your time
um i've i've really enjoyed that and
i've been able to choose how i spend my
time
one more thing you talked a lot about
the prime minister
and ukraine
um number one you think he'll be the
prime minister by the end of the year
still you don't oh yes i think he'll
leave you don't think there will be a
confidence vote you don't think your
colleagues might try and unseat him
that's right you don't think that will
happen i do not think that will happen
well matt hancock thank you for coming
on and i imagine i will see you uh back
in cabinet uh certainly before you hit
50 what do you think
i'm just
i'm just i'm just enjoying life on the
back bench all right thank you very much